this is cereth registered nurse ari and
calm and in this video I want to be
going over the sympathetic nervous
system versus the parasympathetic system
in this video is part of an Inc Lex
review series over the neuro system
along with pharmacology and as always at
the end of this YouTube video don't
forget to access the free quiz so let's
get started so in this video what we're
going to be covering is we're going to
be covering the anatomy of these two
nervous systems where their neurons are
specifically coming out what organs
they're affecting and along with those
signs and symptoms that each system is
producing then we're going to take it a
step further and go over medications
that can either inhibit or stimulate
each system because for in clicks you
want to know those because you need to
know what to look out for in these
patients so the nervous system is made
up of two systems you have this central
nervous system which is the brain and
the spinal cord and this is where
informations going to be processed
through your eyes through ears through
your nose and it's going to send it down
through the spine which is then going to
send it out through neurons through the
peripheral system and it's going to do
what needs to be done now the peripheral
system nervous system can be divided
into two things the somatic or the
autonomic and we're talking about the
autonomic in this video and autonomic is
divided into the sympathetic and the
parasympathetic now the somatic system
is the system that's responsible for
your voluntary actions for instance you
touch something hot your body
immediately senses that and you pull
your arm off
so that was voluntary but with the
autonomic system this controls our
involuntary unconscious things that we
really can't control like our internal
organs how they work in our glands and
our peripheral nervous system is made up
of cranial nerves twelve of those in
thirty-one spinal nerves and here I have
each color-coded and you want to make it
noted where each of these are out
because the opinion if we're talking
about sympathetic or parasympathetic the
neurons are coming off certain sections
so your cranial nerves
up there in the brainstem and then we
have those 31 pairs of spinal nerves so
up here we have our cervical which there
are eight of those then we go down here
in the blue and this is our thoracic and
there's 12 spinal thoracic nerves then
we go down to our lumbar where there are
five then down to the sacral where there
are also five and then down here to the
cockatiel which there is one so now
let's take an in-depth look at these two
systems side by side and see how they
differ and how they are the same now
because they are a part of the autonomic
nervous system they are unique with
their neurons they each have two neurons
that are going to come together and
synapse and again jalaw and then affect
whatever organ they need to and they
differ in the neurotransmitters that
they're releasing especially in that
post ganglionic neuron so I want you to
remember that as we're talking about
because what I'm talking about is these
neurons come out like in the
parasympathetic they come out of the
brain stem and then synapse and then
they go wherever they need to and then
over here with the sympathetic they come
out of certain parts of the spinal cord
and synapse and in effect whatever
organs they need to so first let's look
at our sympathetic nervous system okay
this system is the system responsible
for stress how we respond to stress so
it's known as the fight-or-flight
compared to the parasympathetic which is
known as the rest and digest the
parasympathetic system cares about your
ability to digest food to reproduce and
take it easy on your body the
sympathetic system cares about your
survival getting you out of danger and
preserving your life so you can live and
then once I stress whatever is going on
is gone then this system will kick in
and you can live reproduce and eat food
so where's let's look at the sympathetic
system okay where are these neurons
majorly coming out of they are coming
out of the thoracic in the lumbar areas
so remember that so here we go we have
this preganglionic neuron that's coming
out and it is made up of cholinergic
fibers okay
so what is it going to release as its
neurotransmitter in that gang EULA it's
going to release acetylcholine so
remember that :
cholinergic fibers release acetylcholine
so thatís and Oh choline that
neurotransmitter is going to stimulate
these postganglionic about the
sympathetic nervous system majority of
these neurons are made up of out of
nergic fibers so they're going to
release a chemical called a
neurotransmitter called norepinephrine
and this norepinephrine is going to act
on specifically those alpha and beta
receptors which is why you're going to
see increase heart rate with whenever
the sympathetic system is stimulated
along with bronchodilation and things
like that which we're going to hit on
here in a second and another thing I
want to note because whenever we're
talking about this I really just want
you to commit to memory that most of
these postganglionic neurons are added
made up of a Dinaric fibers which are
going to cause that neuron to release
norepinephrine because it's gonna tie in
with our drugs
however like for instance if this post
ganglionic neuron was going to the sweat
glands it's actually going to be made up
of cholinergic fibers which is going to
release what acetylcholine to simulate
that sweat glamp and here in the
sympathetic it would actually cause you
to sweat so it's going to release the
acetylcholine stimulate the sweat glands
and you're going to be pouring the sweat
that's why when someone's running from
that bear they're sweating a lot or at
this post ganglionic neuron was going to
the renal vessels it's going to be made
up of dopaminergic fibres which is going
to release the neurotransmitter dopamine
to stimulate those kidneys so just keep
that in mind if you're studying this for
nursing school or just for some other
class now let's ask yourself okay how is
this sympathetic nervous system going to
stay stimulated because the peripheral
nervous system can only do so much
because say that we are in danger were
running from that bear and we're gonna
be running for a while because this is a
strong bear and it's hungry and it's
ready to get us so we need something in
our body to help supplement that and to
actually produce these catecholamines
and put them in our blood so we can have
more of them so we can continue running
so we can breathe better our pupils can
be dilated so we can see what's going on
and what's gonna happen coming out of
that spinal cord will be another
preganglionic on to be made of those
cholinergic fibers which is going to
release acetylcholine but it doesn't go
through a ganglia it's going to directly
stimulate our kidney specifically those
adrenal glands the adrenal medulla and
what does that produce or catecholamines
so it's going to release epinephrine and
norepinephrine into that blood so we can
have more of those circulating to keep
us from getting eaten by that bear so
now let's look at those signs and
symptoms that a person will present with
when their sympathetic nervous system is
being stimulated okay so let's look at
these organs okay it's going to
stimulate the eyes and the salivary
glands what's going to happen because
remember it's going to be attaching to
either those alpha beta receptors and we
have various ones of those so with the
eyes what it's gonna do is it's going to
cause the eyes to dilate so you can see
your surroundings better so you can get
away also it's going to cause the
salivary glands not to produce as much
saliva because remember this is dealing
with your survival and Slava plays a
role in digestion and we can digest
later so why over here you're gonna see
that you're gonna have increased saliva
production in here we don't really care
it's gonna really dry up so you're not
gonna have that next your heart and
lungs are gonna be affected and you have
various receptors in the heart and lungs
of these at anergic the norepinephrine
is going to affect and with your heart
it's going to cause tachycardia increase
that heart rate so you can pump more
blood and get away it's also going to
increase your blood pressure and your
lungs are going to be affected as well
you're going to have what's called
bronco
dilation so this Airways open up and you
can inhale more air so you can run and
get out of there now let me throw this
out at you okay
you've heard of at anergic agonist and
at anergic antagonist drugs okay
so let's throw some beta agonist out
there what is a beta agonist drug going
to do it's going to cause the effects of
the sympathetic system because agonist
means it's with its working together so
you give a person like a beta agonist
drug it's going to cause bronchodilation
they're gonna breathe better for
instance like whenever we talked about
in our asthma video we give them beta
agonist like albuterol to cause
bronchodilation because they're having
bronco constriction so see how all
that's time together and then another
thing if we were giving like a beta
antagonist antagonist means it's going
against like for instance say a beta
blocker like propanolol what's that
gonna do if it's going against what's
happening in the beta receptors it's
gonna do the opposite effect it's going
to cause the heart rate to come down now
also can stimulate the liver and what's
it going to do with that the liver it's
going to cause the liver to perform a
function called glycogen license a
license and this is going to increase
our blood sugar so release those stores
of glucose for us so we can have the
energy to get out of their intestines
it's gonna slow down the mobility of the
intestines because we don't care about
digestion bladder it's going to cause
the bladder to relax you're not gonna be
urinating you're not gonna be pain so it
won't constrict like over here we have a
constriction also relax the uterus and
the sweating like how we talked about
earlier and we have all those nice
catecholamines going through the body to
help continue this cycle for the
sympathetic nervous system now let's
look at our parasympathetic system
okay so again this is the rest and
digest
so let's say that our stress stimuli is
gone we're safe we're out of harm's way
so now our parasympathetic system is
going to kick in and it's going to allow
us to relax to kick up our feet and eat
digest that food reproduce do whatever
because we're no longer in danger so in
a sense is going to really undo what the
sympathetic system did to our body and
help us recover because if we had the
sympathetic system going on 24/7 our
heart and our body is just going to wear
out we're gonna collapse so we really
need this parasympathetic system to come
in and help us recover maintain this
balance in our life now there are some
differences with the parasympathetic
system compared to the sympathetic and
one thing is if you take a look at the
preganglionic neurons versus the
postganglionic neurons notice the length
over here in the sympathetic those
preganglionic neurons are a lot shorter
and the post are a lot longer compared
over here they're a lot longer the pre
and the post are a lot shorter so keep
that in mind also where they originate
where they're coming out up over here in
the parasympathetic they're coming out
of mainly the brainstem and they're
messing with the cranial nerves they're
responsible for simulating those cranial
nerves specifically 3 7 & 9 and then you
also have the vagus and I want you to
remember the vagus cranial nerve 10
because it's the longest cranial nerve
and it's the most important for causing
the signs and symptoms that you see in
the parasympathetic system because it's
targeting the heart the lungs the GI
system so really why you're seeing all
those certain signs and symptoms in the
parasympathetic is because of the
stimulation of cranial nerve 10 the
vagus nerve and then it's also down in
this sacral area and it's gonna simulate
like the bladder and your uterus and
things like that
okay so let's backtrack and go up here
okay so we have our pre ganglionic
neuron and it's made up call anergic
fiber so what's it going to release
acetylcholine and it's gonna synapse
in this gang gula up here it's a little
bit different down in these areas so
keep that in mind and like the cranium
ganglia so synapse in their releases a
neurotransmitter that stimulates the
postganglionic neuron which is also a
call and nergic fiber so it's going to
release the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine as well and because these
are coming from cranial nerve three
seven and nine these are going to affect
the eyes and the salivary glands so your
eyes are going to constrict instead of
dilate and you're going to produce some
slaughter then have the same concept
coming out with the vagus nerve releases
acetylcholine but this is going to
synapse in a terminal gang gula which is
within the plexus of that visceral organ
that it's affecting so it's affecting
the heart the lungs the GI system and
here in a second we'll cover those signs
and symptoms then down the sacral area
you have the preganglionic neuron which
is going to release again acetylcholine
and effect and it's actually going to
synapse in the wall of the organ at the
pelvic ganglia and then the
postganglionic choline and affect its
organ now let's look at those signs and
symptoms that will present when that
parasympathetic system is simulated and
it's going to be the opposite of this
sympathetic system because we need to
undo everything that happened over here
when we were stress so with these
cranial nerves what's going to happen
when they're stimulated especially these
up here the eyes the pupils are going to
constrict instead of being dilated
they're gonna relax and constrict our
saliva glands are going to produce more
slava because we're ready to eat we've
got to give more food to replenish our
body from its energy its loss like our
glucose and build up everything else
that we've lost over there so Slava
plays a role in digestion so we'll have
increased with that also our heart and
lungs is going to be affected instead of
beating super fast and helping us dilate
our Airways to breathe the heart's going
to slow down and it's gonna relax which
is going to relax the arteries and lower
blood pressure and our bronchioles don't
need to be not nice and
I light it anymore they're gonna relax
downward so bronchoconstriction also the
stomach and the GI system it's going to
increase gastric motility because you're
going to get food in there and it's
going to play a role in absorbing that
and then valve mu bowel movements can
happen along with the bladder which will
allow the bladder to constrict contract
and which will help with voiding so as
you can see whenever we are super
stressed or sympathetic system it's
going to be an overdrive helping us
survive but the parasympathetic system
is going to kick in help us relax eat
rest digest and continue off now let's
switch gears and look at the medications
that can stimulate each of these systems
because sometimes we want these systems
to be stimulated based on what's going
on with the patient first let's look at
the sympathetic why in the world would
we want to stimulate a lot of lot
response in a patient well a patient who
is on the verge of death or in shock
their blood pressure super low they're
not doing good or maybe they're having
severe Branko constriction from an
anaphylactic reaction we need to save
their life because their sympathetic
nervous system really isn't doing its
job so we can give them medications and
these category drugs are called sympathy
mimetics mimetic hints mimics it mimics
the sympathetic nervous system and these
are also called odd anergic agonist and
the reason we just learned is because
that postganglionic neuron is made of
out of nergic fibers which release the
neurotransmitter norepinephrine and
cause all those fight-or-flight response
so what are some drugs
we have dopamine we can give this in a
drip and titrate it based on whatever we
want for our parameters this will help
increase blood pressure and increase
cardiac output it can also act on those
alpha and beta receptors to increase
renal perfusion another thing we can
give is an or norepinephrine also called
the brand name Levophed that's one of
those drips we can give and this can
help increase blood pressure
another thing is epinephrine
like in the EpiPen patient have an
anaphylactic reaction
give that to themselves it will cause
bronchodilation and they can breathe in
not have the NF lactic reaction so can
you see that these right here are
stimulating our sympathetic nervous
system cuz at this point in time we need
it another thing like I talked about
earlier where the beta to anergic
agonist and these can be prescribed in
the inhale route and you give this to
patients who are having respiratory
problems like COPD asthma and those
drugs include like albuterol saw you
meter all and a butyl as a short-acting
and so you meter roll is a long-acting
now let's look at our side effects okay
so what are you going to expect to see
in these patients who are having these
drugs because our sympathetic nervous
system is being simulated so you're
gonna see symptoms of the sympathetic
nervous system being simulated so how is
the heart rate going to be gonna be high
or low it's gonna be high cuz we got a
fight-or-flight response going on so
that's gonna happen how do you think
their blood glucose is going to be well
they're on these for a long enough being
simulated got the fight-or-flight
response we have our liver performing
glyco good glycogen a lysis so it can be
increased so we can have hyper glycine
you gotta watch out for that how are
they going to feel emotionally if
they're on this for a long time they're
gonna be nervous they're gonna feel
jittery because they have this constant
stimulation of this sympathetic nervous
system and it's really made for us to
get out of danger but here these
patients need this
how are the mucous membranes going to be
are they going to be really moist or
they let me drive they're gonna be dry
because our body doesn't care about
digesting food whenever we're on these
because this is being stimulated and we
can worry about that later now let's
look at the drugs that stimulate the
parasympathetic system okay these drugs
are called parasympathetics so they're
gonna mimic
the parasympathetic system and these
drugs are also referred to as
cholinergic drugs which is a lot easier
to say and a type of drug I want to
point out because we are going to be
covering myasthenia gravis and which is
gonna be part of our neuro series so a
drug that has cholinergic effects on the
body is called parados stigma and what
is going on in my escena gravis well a
lot of patients are different depending
on their signs and symptoms but they can
struggle with muscle weakness and a lot
of times they'll have facial drooping or
eye problems so they'll have weakness
and the eyes are in the face and a lot
of this in a nutshell is due to the
decrease acetylcholine receptors and
remember we just learned from our
anatomy that we would just went over
that there's cholinergic fibers and
those postganglionic neurons release
acetylcholine which is going to help
with all those cranial nerves being able
to do their job in the face and in the
eyes well if we don't have enough of
those that's not being stimulated so
it's just going to droop and it's not
going to be able to have its contraction
and be able to present correctly so you
can give this drug throw more of it
which can cause the corner don't type
effect so it can contract and the drug
can help that patient maintain normal
muscle function so how is that's where
we actually want to cause a call energic
effect now if a patient's taking this
what's gonna what are some side effects
well the side effects are going to be
what would happen with our
parasympathetic nervous system being
stimulated because we're stimulating
that system so what's going to happen
with their pupil size they're going to
have smaller pupils so they're going to
constrict and what is going to happen
with slava are they gonna have issues
with lots of slav in the mouth yes
they're gonna have constant increase
production of saliva which can be
troublesome for many patients also
because we're increasing Nath mucus
production is going to be increased so
they can struggle with coughing because
in those Airways goblet cells producing
all that me
so we can have increase of that so
increased mucus can lead to coughing and
what was another thing that those
cholinergic drugs the parasympathetic
system can do it stimulates gastric the
intestines motility so what's going to
happen those intestines are constantly
gonna be moving there may not be
digesting their food very well so they
can suffer with diarrhea stomach pains
and cramping now let's look at drugs
that inhibit each system ok so
sympathetic system ok drug categories
are called sympathy lytic and they're
also referred to as at an urgent and
tagging as' and we talked a little bit
about this earlier so what these drugs
are gonna do is that they're gonna stop
that nerve impulse and that post
ganglionic neuron and stop that neuron
from releasing that norepinephrine so
you don't get the increased heart rate
bronchodilation all of that so it's
blocking that so what kind of signs and
symptoms do you think it would cause it
would lead to the opposite so
parasympathetic types and symptoms so
why would you want to initiate or stop a
sympathetic nervous system response if
the patient is has hypertension high
blood pressure or they have like an
anxiety disorder because all those are
signs and symptoms of the sympathetic
system being initiated so sometimes are
like beta blockers and they can be
selective or non-selective depending on
what receptor they target and that can
help lower the heart rate for instance
like propanolol so tall things like that
so how do you expect it to work what are
the side effects of these medications
well they're gonna call us the opposite
so you give someone propanolol they have
tachycardia that's why you would give it
and so what would it do it would lower
the heart rate so decrease heart rate
and one thing you would want to watch
out for is decreasing the heart rate too
low so bradycardia airway what's
something that can happen with these
well you could they can cause
bronchoconstriction which is why you
have to watch out whenever you're giving
patients who are received
those non-selective beta blockers
because they can target the receptors in
the lungs the beta of receptors in the
lungs and it can cause
bronchoconstriction so you wouldn't want
to do that with a patient with asthma so
it could constrict possibly if it is one
of those non-selective tops also it can
help bring down the blood pressure as
well because since we're having some
parasympathetic signs and symptoms
because we're stopping the sympathetic
system
okay so parasympathetic what are some
drugs that can inhibit that response
well parasympathetic drugs also called
anticholinergic now remember the other
ones were callin urging so these are
anticholinergic so it's stopping that
post ganglionic neuron which is made up
of cholinergic fibers from releasing
that acetylcholine so you're not going
to get that response so in the flipside
you're gonna get like signs and symptoms
that you would see in the sympathetic
nervous system so they can target
various areas of the body and some
things I just want to throw out to help
you understand this like for instance
with the airway say this patient has
asthma they can't really tolerate one of
these other drugs that dilate the heart
rate like i'll i mean dilate the
respiratory system like i'll be a role
because it can cause tachycardia and
makes them really nervous so instead you
could give them an anticholinergic
bronchodilator like a pro tropen and
that can help with that dilate the lungs
instead of having constriction because
call anergic remember allowed
bronchoconstriction and said we want to
dilate so this is doing the opposite
also you can give a drug that can affect
the heart so what drug can do that if a
patient is having episodes of severe
bradycardia what's one of those drugs
that we get to increase the heart rate
atropine so we can give atropine to
increase the heart rate that's one of
those anticholinergics so it increase
also atropine can be given to dilate the
pupils after surgery or if they have
something wrong with their eyes like
inflammation
or something like that where they would
need to dilate the eyes so who do the
opposite of what a cholinergic drug
would do which could constrict the pupil
so this will dilate the pupils okay so
that wraps up this review of the
sympathetic nervous system versus the
parasympathetic thank you so much for
watching don't forget to take the free
quiz and to subscribe to our channel for
more videos